with respect to saying this is hate this
is anti-Semitism this is racism but
we're going to allow it so on CNBC
business they had Mark Rowan on now Mark
Rowan is the chair of University of
Pennsylvania pen upen uh their Wharton
School of Business Wharton School of
Business by the way is probably the most
well-known School of Business in the
entire world uh Donald Trump even went
to wen School of Business uh here's Mark
Rowan proud you know proudly and doing
the right thing and it's so refreshing
when someone does the right thing
calling out the president of upen her
name is Elizabeth McGill because she
refuses to issue a strongly worded
statement against Hamas he he does a
really nice job here take a look well
you this is your Alma M so let's let's
just talk about how this came about what
was going through your head uh what kind
of conversations you've had that led you
to write this look this is not at the
end of the day about Free Speech because
I whether people like it or not uh me
personally and most people support Free
Speech there are always going to be
racists and haters this is is about a
university condone conference University
professors University supported and the
inability of leadership to exercise any
sort of Mor moral Clarity with respect
to saying this is hate this is
anti-Semitism this is racism but we're
going to allow it that condemnation
should not be so hard you know
microaggressions are condemned with
extreme moral outrage and yet violence
particularly violence against Jews
anti-Semitism seems to have found a
place Tolerance on the campus uh
protected by Free Speech uh president
Mill is not an anti-semite president
Mill is just not capable of exercising
moral leadership I love the line there
so I so I don't know anything obviously
about the president but if but beyond
what I'm hearing related to this I don't
think it's useful or um it's it's useful
or it's likely untrue let's say that
she's an anti-semite like that the
president of upen like hates Jews but
he's right what she is is a coward a
moral coward which also gets us back to
the Pete Davidson thing at the beginning
right that there's this group of people
that at these universities they've
called for microaggressions and safe
spaces we've been doing this for years
right guys years and years I've been
called a Nazi and all right because I
was mocking this stuff for years that's
what they've been doing at colleges then
they get a group a bunch of kids out
there calling for genocide tearing down
uh you know leaflets and posters of kids
who are kidna
blah blah blah blah blah nobody
condemning any of the outrageous things
that have happened and not only do they
allow it on campus and we can have that
discussion related to free speech I
believe in free speech and free
expression there there are some caveats
around that related to when you start
calling for the death of people it could
be a problem but it's but as his point
is it's not just that they're allowing
it right and he wants it to be allowed
within the confines of the law it's that
they won't issue a statement saying oh
there is a clear moral uh position here
to take which is that killing innocent
people is bad right burning babies alive
is
bad